no dammit get out I do for Lord I do
Manon dammit
come on Felix you can do this let's get
that overflew another you laughs you're
loose come on come on I can do this this
is the one you know why you know why I
know this is the one because I asked you
guys to send me in your funniest clip
it's not gonna be funny because I know
how unfunny you are just purely based
off the comment section you guys judge
me all the time all this video was in
that gray Oh PewDiePie you make the same
content oh you never make anything
original oh okay how about your comments
meant Clorox bleach references whatever
same Chebarkul same Chebarkul every time
we're in this together okay we're all in
this together
let's go PewDiePie plays all-star Smash
Mouth on recorder
oh hi the face I make as well alright I
didn't laughs whatever
whatever next one PewDiePie makes
original content
oh he's streaming Pub gee what do you
mean I upload every single day an
original can't stop this is ridiculous
also we can't show the frog so blur the
frog and replace it with something not
racist please like a gazebo Thank You
person what do you do for a living Felix
I draw penis okay fine I mean I wanted
to see more not in that way we just just
felt a little short as though we're
gonna have a segment called Felix
favorites
that's right Felix favorites from the
week this one is beautiful they're
playing veer and I don't know I guess
they're going in for a kiss I love that
I love the chat as well in the bank run
do it do it hey call them anime to 505
what a goddamn [ __ ] block
look at that just swooshes in and that
face - someone needs to edit that better
you could do a better editor of that
still closer than I'll ever get pretty
pie reacts to things go Scott the thing
goes boop boop boop baby big skippity
buck no no no no no no no no no no no
you guys just love getting me in trouble
huh yes oh well done that guy got me get
me the sound of Australia gonna be a
didgeridoo isn't it
[Music]
what a shocker
there's nothing funnier trust me I've
seen it it was in the last episode I
can't show this I just can i'll this
link it cuz it's funny oh oh
PewDiePie said a naughty word on the
Internet and now he's gonna pay oh yes
that one wins you win Congrats let me
tell you a secret I've seen that bet you
know we're sitting here right now and if
you guys want to take a station break
you can but if you call me because to my
face one more time honey ginger ice you
better not one more time we go to take a
station break it's a five-minute segment
our five segments show we got a long way
to go we do we got a long way to go we
do I'll get a couple segments well it's
good to know they're talking like this
behind my back for long but now I said
it right here right again no problems
that I think that you probably won't say
it again
I bet I do okay Chris
Oh myoh ah motion data well you know you
don't call people Chris they don't like
it everyone knows that ridiculous of
this television person that would have
been a truly you laugh you lose for me
I've seen the video before so I knew how
to hold my character but on the inside I
am laughing hysterically it is the
funniest I have ever seen but I can't
laugh at this I think we both can agree
and understand why and what do we have
here well well well
[Music]
beautiful
what a perfect at it well done
[Music]
Oh
oh my god well done on the edit
I need to finish K on I stopped washing
it yes why is there no sound oh come on
it would have been so good what actually
happens in the matrix
the only thing fault ly with the movie
is this part right there I'm glad
someone finally fixed it yeah damned
[Music]
well done all right there was mildly
funny it was worth a little chuckle cuz
it was clever good job
what do we have here well he wasn't
lying there was consequences that's the
joke everyone that was the joke
you will die laughing okay sure sure
I'll be the judge of that to actually
digest and go through the documentation
that is going to the presented to the
public and the opportunity for proper
engagement is actually after the tabling
of the year what is it that was funny to
you well done good job what I say at the
beginning of this video what I said
Ethan interviews pewdie without saying a
word me and Ethan after all the latest
drama this summarizes it pretty well we
practically hate each other now rest in
peace sleepy oh no it's like we don't do
it no sleeping no today
oh hey sleepy I want to show you
something how does that make you feel oh
we need to end this episode now leave a
like remember to check out the reddit
okay post more and also please don't
post anything copyrighted okay
videogames
that's okay alright and it means that
we'll do original content that would be
the best if you could do original
content that would be a plus thank you
guys so much for watching and
[Music]